foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar a
scalable miniature circular gen Circle
DS DNA production system for Gene and
cell therapy
I am Cassie saltman of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by genscript to learn more visit
genscript.com
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits after the webinar
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
fan job senior scientist at genscript
novel therapeutic materials R D team
Dr Zhao you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today on the webinar
a scalable miniature circular Gene
Circle DS DNA production system forging
and cell therapy my name is Benjo
I'm a senior scientist of molecular
biology at gen Square
today I'm going to spend about 10 about
30 minutes to overview the gene Circle
DS DNA include including the following
five aspects
the first is the background about
plasmate
circular DS DNA for GCT
and next is the product or the
introduction of between Circle TSD and a
development
and
the next is the applications we can use
the Jing Circle we need to improve the
performance or reduce the risk
and next is the manufacturing and
accuracy specification
include including two purities levels of
the are your greatest services
and the fifth is how to design your
constructs and customize your chainsaw
course
classmate has been commonly used as a
vector system to provide genetic
information in non-virology and cell
therapy or DNA vaccine although much
safer than viral approaches
plasmid vectors
generally to encode
antibiotic resistant genes in backbone
this antibiotic resistant Gene markers
as well as
the bacterial region constitute a
possible City risk
and and they are associated with a
structural
plasmid instability and
this and decrease
Gene delivery efficiency
these drawbacks have initiated the
development of various many plasmid or
circular TS DNA free of antibiotic
resistant markers for example the plasma
with a selection system based on
the operator repressed titration
or selection based on the RNA and the
RNA interactions
and the mini intronic plasmid whose
replication and selections uh
elements are placed within an engineered
intro in the eukaryotic expression
system and the famous mini Circle
devoid of adding prokaryotic
backbone including the replication or
region
so
these normal classes of plasmid or
circular DS DNA indicate a trend of
plasma development
and that is we want we want lower cell
toxicity and lower immuno response
so the backbone should have minimized
the size and free of CPT Island
we want higher expression efficiency and
the longer duration so
we should eliminate the capital region
to avoid transcription silencing
and it is also important to reduce
probability risk
caused by an anti caused by the use of
antibiotics and is related antibiotic
resistant genes
and the last but not least
the plasmid
manufacturing should be easy to operate
and easy to scale up
and can meet the GMP equality
requirements
thank you
now I'd like to introduce a novel
circular DS DNA system named Gene Circle
dsdna and its production method
ginso called DS DNA is
a small circular DNA Vector forging
expression or insertion
there is only
429 base pair the size of vector
backbone contains mainly a replication
or region
it is free of antibiotic resistant Gene
or any other selection markers
there is no cpg island or
bacterial region sequences in better
backbone
so it has a many advantages over a
conventional plasmid
it can avoid regular regulatory concern
for transgenetic drugs resistance and
has lower
cytotoxicity and immunogenicity
and have better stability and
transfection efficiency it also can
increase
locking efficiency or wire tighter or
RNA and the protein expression level
now I will show you how Gene circle is
produced
firstly we construct a specific
parental plasmid
the plasma contains selection marker and
functional and elements
as well as a pair of
recombination sites
next
post bacteria is transformed with the
perendoplasmid
and positive columnies are selected
then
we induce the expression of recombine
recombinase
and self recombination is occurred
the parental plasmid is separated into
one molecular of Gene Circle mini
plasmid
and one molecular of circular
selection marker with parental plasmid
backboard
then
because of the parent of that one circle
is not able to replicate
it will be removed quickly during the
bacterial growth
the King Circle has a much higher copy
number than parental classmate so to
insert hole
become dominant and soon replaced the
parental plasmid completely
due to the plasmid incompatibility
as a result
over
80 percent of the E coli cells
carry pure
Circle and
are without antibiotic resistance
it is verified by NGS analysis
then single colonies are picked out for
sale Banking and plasmated fermentation
that is the basic mechanism of Gene
Circle production
gen Circle can be used in virus
barrier can be used in various
applications in
group in a replace of conventional
plasmids to eliminate the about safety
concern and improve the performance it
can be used in the cell therapy as the
crystal knocking template
or the
Trend or the transgene vector for the
transposons
or it can be used in gene therapy as the
material for a virus Packaging
or used as the non-viral gene of
Interest factors or as a material to
protect the MRA
it also can be used in DNA vaccine to
to express the antigen
and it it can be used in the disease
modeling and Gene function
study
now let me show some details of case
studies the first one is the HDR
knocking acid
we use the gene Circle as the template
as the template for HDR knocking
compared we compared the chain circle
with the traditional plasmid
for example the pack
made
um it shows much higher and knocking
efficiency compared to the
conventional plasmid the knocking
efficiency increased up to 30 percent
compared to the conventional plasmid and
the other benefit is that no risk of
just genetic antibiotic resistance
and recently we get we achieved a higher
knocking efficiency
by optimized by optimizing the
transfection conditions we observed as
high as
57 percent of knocking efficiency
using the gene Circle as knocking
template
and also low cell toxicity was observed
and Chin circles can also be used in
transposal systems now we show the
piggyback transposal system and using
the chain Circle as the transgene vector
and we also compared with the uh
the traditional plasmid
it shows an increased efficiency up to
15 percent compared to the conventional
plasmids
and in Sleeping Beauty transposon system
um it can we we should we also observed
a high integration efficiency up to 45
percent
engine Circle works well in both double
plasmid system and the plasmid plus mRNA
system
for
in
the application of virus packaging the
chain Circle can replace the
conventional plasmid as the as the
packaging vector or the trans or the
transfer vectors
in antivirus better
packaging and Airway Packaging
we observed a increased virus title
and not and no antibiotic resistance
Gene were detected in the
virus particles
for the applications
of in Vivo or acceptable gene expression
the chain Circle also showed a superior
performance
compared to the the traditional plasmid
it shows
um
increased transcription level
and the transcription level increased
four-fold compared to the conventional
plasmid this is a
mouse assay that to
uh the most tail rain injection with
naked DNA and we monitor the the
RNA level after nine hours after the
injection
it shows it shows for fold
higher than the traditional plasma
the chain script have the IP of ginso
called DS DNA as well as its related
process
um the complete manufacturing workflow
include
in the gene synthesis and the parental
plasmic cloning and the gene Circle cell
Banking and implementation and massive
prep and QC
engine script we can provide a gene
Circle preparation services from genes
synthesis to a maxi prep within two to
eight weeks of turnaround time in total
foreign
Circle systems shows good compatibility
with various lengths of inserts and
complex sequences such as
itrs of aav or long inverted repeats can
be also produced
stably
besides sequence stability
a chin Circle also shows Superior
homogeneity
over 90 percent supercoil the supercoil
monomer is detected in the final product
for are you
the QC specifications are listed for the
rule grade Gene Circle Services we put
we provide two different Purity levels
for different asses and target cells
foreign
your construct with string circles and
customize your Gene Circle product
as I mentioned I suggested I mentioned
chain Circle can be used in various
applications such as gene expression the
HDR template the transposons and aov or
lentivirus transfer a vector
so you when you design your construct in
gene expression because the gene Circle
the backbone of zinc Circle contains
only
um replica
replication or region
or backbone so so you must
include all the element of the
functional element
for a gene expression
in your engine of Interest
um for example the promoters
the ORF the poly a or Terminator and the
it and
necessary utr
for net for HDR locking template and you
should
you should
include the chain of insertion as well
as the
the ha sequences
in your inserts
for transposal applications
the idrs of the transposon
and the gene
expression cassette for integration
should be included
and the next
for the AV transfer
vectors the the insert should include an
ITR and the forecast of transport chain
okay
and also for the lantivirus a transfer
Vector construction
the LTR with functional elements and
transfer Gene
should be included
now we we can provide the
the areol chainsaw Corporation Services
as a my as I just mentioned the rule
grade of Gene Circle
services
have a there is two different
Purity level
of Industrial Level and pre-clinical
level the inter the industrial level is
recommended to be used for the viral
Vector packaging or the cell line test
and the pre-clinical level of
the gene Circle and
has much lower toxicity so it is
suggests
it is recommended to be used in a
primary TCL or nkcl engineering or
animal assets
and we we also recommend to use the
pre-clinical grade of Gene Circle dsdna
in crispr
HDR knocking assay and we have observed
a
significant increase of knocking
efficiency compared to the conventional
plasmid
and we are also planning the GMP grade
of Gene circles and it is to be
determined
and
in the fourth quarter of this year
for the r d
applications and the early
clinical trial
we provide from a microgram to Grand
scale
and and the option of the delivery form
such as the freeze stride
or the liquid and the buffer is also
optional
so that's all for my presentation and
thank you for your time with me today
now if you have any questions I will be
happy to answer them thank you
foreign
thank you Dr Zhao for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how long does production take and what
is the expected turnaround time for an
order
foreign
the production takes from two weeks to
eight weeks in total it depends on the
lens and the context sequence in your
GOI
generally the production of Gene Circle
takes only three
additional three days of additional time
for recombination and self selection
thank you
okay now question does genscript offer
an animal free production option for Gen
Circle
yes we have animal free production
options
as and it also race
okay
great our next question can I perform
the plasmid preparation myself
um actually because the gene so-called
Lacks
the selection marker so the E coli
cannot be transformed with during Circle
DS DNA so it cannot be reproduced
with only the gene Circle the DNA
thank you
okay great and it looks like we have
time for one more question
what are the minimum and maximum insert
lengths for Gen Circle dsdna
has a good compatibility with various
lengths of inserts
but one one KB to 8 KB is preferable
thank you
okay thank you Dr Zhao do you have any
final comments for our audience
um yeah and I think if you if you are
interested in jinx.com you can feel free
to contact me or my colleagues we are
very happy to share more details about
it and help you with your essays thank
you
thank you again Dr Zhao for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank labroots and
our sponsor genscript for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye